thrilled to have here one of the stars
of the film Ford versus Ferrari that's
in theaters near you one week from today
certainly many sports fans know this man
from his role as of the legendary Don
Haskins and glory road good to see you
Josh Lucas how are you sir very happy to
be very thrilled that you are indeed
here ok there's so many different ways
to go with this conversation Ford versus
Ferrari now when I I saw it and I went
into it thinking at all honestly because
I was totally blind as to what it was
about I thought that the Christian Bale
character was driving a car and the Matt
Damon character whose plays Carroll
Shelby one of the most famous drivers
who became something completely else in
terms of a I guess the designer builder
the grandfather of designing and
building sure I thought that they would
be the antagonists in a way and they're
the protagonists on the same side what
do you want people to know about this
movie before going into it Josh I think
it's rather clear that this is a you
know fun race car movie and the reality
is I think what you and I were just
talking about before the segment began
which is that the movie is deeply about
something else it's not just about
friendship it's not just about America
it's about history it's about corporate
politics it's about it means all these
incredibly deep and interesting ideas
that are underneath it which is yes it's
a thrilling Disney racecar movie but
it's actually a none of us it's very
interesting I think maybe Christian Bale
is probably the most interested in race
cars Matt Damon the director myself none
of us kind of thought or cared about
race cars as a whole we were really
interested in the human drama of at all
or the human story that is so much more
alive and it was so we were saying Jon
Bernthal a really wonderful actor took
his six year old news eight year old to
see the movie and not only did they
really love the movie but the next day
they had this really deep and long
conversation the two boys about the
ideas of the movie because they didn't
they were they wanted to know like why
would my character and I play this guy
Lee obvy were too
do not want the best race car driver and
Jon Bernthal was trying to understand
understand the idea of what it meant to
be a bohemian what it meant to be
somebody who is you could say even in
today's vernacular a degenerate it's
very on corporate like you know Ken
miles the the the racecar driver who
Christian Bell plays very non Ford not
buttoned up not suited like you would be
you're a slick executive for the Ford
Motor Company and he is just an absolute
total wildcard driver that you clearly
need behind a car right he's an
individual and it was it was just fun
watching all of these vast characters
just bash into one another around an
amazing time of race car driving back in
1966 with the 24 Hours of LeMans and
there was some neat moments that looked
like the Wide World of Sports from way
back in the day ABC notes of everything
do you know this Bob Iger is the head of
Disney sure has a further difference
well no but he was the producer on that
segment no kidding in 1966 he was or the
wide world or the wild world of sports
that's how he started he was a sports
producer for ABC very few people know
this about him and that that's he
particularly has a passion for this
movie oddly enough for glory road as
well because that's the world he comes
from no kidding that is Bob Iger on the
show do you could ask him he will come
on this show because he would like to
talk about his book his book his story I
know he's selling I know he's selling a
book and obviously this film as well so
how did you how did you prefer prepare
for the role here I mean because you had
to learn about this exactly OBB he's a
real person right part of it look it
comes down to kind of the joke of it all
like Leo Beebe the hair stylist very
complicated funny hairstyle in the movie
and it was because every photograph I
saw this guy had this hairstyle yeah
which was again sort of his own weird
individualism I mean the Ford Motor
Company at that point was like the FBI
they all dressed a certain way they they
had a certain level of a blue blood look
right and Leo Beebe weirdly enough was
you know one of the top guys he was in a
tank in World War 2 with henry ford ii
he had this tremendous and deep
friendship and he believed and not just
his great friend Henry Ford but he
believed in the Ford Motor Company as an
iconic American important company for
the image of the idea of what America is
which goes down to kind of what the
story's about right even down to this
style that he had was was purposeful and
there was the sense of this dignity that
I think he had and there's this sense
that he wanted America and to be
presented a certain way and that's where
the story gets super complicated well
certainly because America being
presented in a certain way when it was a
Ford Motor Company and this is what the
movies about essentially is it wasn't
about winning races like this not going
on the international race world and
winning the 24 Hours of LeMans as
Carroll Shelby did however not in an
American car sure so getting Carroll
Shelby to figure out how to get a Ford
car up to speed to beat Ferrari and that
is just it's just a fun look at how this
all went down and I'm sure it was very
serious at the time and part of the joy
of the movie making in the craziness of
the movie making is that and that's
Tracy that's the actor who you're saying
a place Henry Ford says he's amazing
this is an analog movie meaning we're
actually watching there's no CGI in this
movie were very little it's entirely
practical so they had to collect cars
for years before they made the movie to
make the factory of Ford's they had to
get Ford Fairlanes is what they were
from 1964 yeah hundreds of them all over
the country build them rebuild them tear
them apart you know all these different
things that were going on for so long in
pre-production to you know imagine
there's a point where you walk into the
Ferrari factory right at one point in
the film I was in a room where there was
200 million dollars of Ferraris because
there was one car alone that cost 68
million dollars
my owner of it was a billionaire who was
sat stood next to the car afraid that
the production would dent his car I was
like you're a billionaire with the 68
car why did you loan it to this movie
right but there's that that car loan I
think is the most expensive car in the
world I guess it doesn't matter how much
money you have if you are worth 68
million dollars you're gonna stand guard
to make sure nobody just you know opens
a door accidentally into it there's a
little ding absolutely that's amazing
yeah the car I mean everything looks so
authentic and so great again Matt Damon
Christian Bale and you Josh Lucas in
Ford versus Ferrari in theaters near you
one week from today right here on the
Rich Eisen show let's get into glory
Road Josh when you were reached out to
to play Donna Haskins
well one of the first calls you make was
to Don Haskins - how did you get
involved with this film
Josh it's funny - go back to Matt Damon
because Ben Affleck was originally gonna
play Don Haskins and he dropped out at
the last minute no that's all saying
would I show up and Texas to start this
movie the first person I met was Hoskins
who walked up to me and basically
punched me in the belly and said you
better gain some weight I was like wow
man okay and he was like he's like
you're not big enough you're not you're
not you know you know and immediately I
had this relationship with him which was
sort of as a father figure and an
Intimidator and all the different things
that Haskins really was you know that
movie I really loved that movie
it's Finn for good reason Josh and that
movie is interesting too because that is
what Don Haskins wanted which is the
rated PG Disney version of his story the
reality is if Don Haskins was as rough
and tough and tumble of a coach I love
this guy as much as anybody on earth as
Bobby Knight he was a true force and his
players would fight to the death for him
in a way that was was quite rare and yet
he was also intimidating at a level very
few coaches on earth
gar but what's interesting is that he
had their respect massively I truly
think that he was colorblind I don't
think he thought about black or white
and color at all mm-hmm I think he truly
was addicted to performance at a level
that is you know out there with and that
movie was amazing for me because my my
technical advisors were Pat Riley I
played on the Kentucky team yeah right
Tim Floyd yeah you know and Don Haskins
so I had these guys in my ear to the
point where I had to like tell them like
I won't point a screamed I mean I'm not
a coach making a movie I'm not coaching
a basketball team right particularly
Riley was on me a couple times
okay let's Pat Riley on you probably be
on his players for authenticity and for
excellence you know like he he genuinely
Pat Riley's are really interesting I I
learned one thing
tremendous from Riley he said once the
day you turn 40 you should get a serious
physical every year you know I was like
why and he said because you want to know
you want to be able to maintain your
level of physical health and physical
health and mental health and excellence
like it comes down to being on top and
being prepared right everything is about
preparation and everything is about
knowledge everything is about even data
like he and he his excellence comes down
to the way that he inspires the way that
he pushes himself and Haskins had that
Floyd these guys are you know seminal or
legendary coaches yes because of their
own Drive towards their own excellence
so how did how did your relationship
with Don Haskins evolved on the set of
to the end we were driving around Texas
and the dirt roads and Outback drinking
tequila no yeah it was great yeah he
became a true friend of mine I love that
man I mean he was genuinely a father
figure for me I think he what it what it
came down to this is a story I haven't
told ok when the movie was first really
or before the movie was released we did
a premiere showing in El Paso Texas for
the team for the actual team the Don
Haskins and the surviving members or
wherever was around
they did not like the movie because they
felt that my performance did not capture
the intensity of Don Haskins and they
were upset about it because they said
Don Haskins was the most powerful force
that they had ever come in contact with
Don Haskins loved the movie because he
said I portrayed him in a in a
flattering light and they shifted gears
when they realized that this is the
Disney version of that story that this
is the the the very how do I put this
the but my point is that I did the
version that Don Haskins wanted mm-hmm
Don Haskins was a there's the rated PG
version and there's the rated hard-r
version yes and they they in real life
had the rated heart hour version which
is a different movie of course I'm sure
it must be and so how did you reconcile
all this well I didn't because I I knew
going into it that I was telling Don
Haskins versions of the way he wanted it
to be and Haskins loves the movie and
his family loved the movie and so and
they then learned that Oh people really
liked the movies so that there wasn't a
sense I think what they felt is that I
wasn't that the character that I
portrayed in the movie wasn't as rough
on them as he was they wanted to be they
wanted to show how much pain they had
been through I could only imagine I mean
anybody can only imagine and obviously
there's been so many documentaries on
this since then and before then about
what the players must have gone through
must have gone through just to even get
to the title game
and then of all people Adolph Rupp and
the in the Kentucky Wildcats of all the
teams that they'd have to go against so
maybe that's they were hoping to see the
full warts-and-all version I think
that's exactly what it was I think they
were wanting to see they as much as the
racial issue is draw driving force of
that season and that story the reality
is is that they played in terror of Don
Haskins they didn't play in terror of
right that was the bigger thing that
Hoskins was able to manipulate and use
within how he played them how he was a
true coach and that true coach has in a
demanding excellence at a level that
he's also can be very manipulative
that's a to go back to Pat Riley
Pat Riley I think is very clear about
how he does that as well how he he
figures out psychology in terms of he
told me I think there's gonna be getting
probably a trouble for saying this he
told me in terms of the way he would
manipulate Shaq about food and about
money like he used these these really
conceptual psychological issues in terms
of coaching and that's what Hoskins does
as well as what Bobby Knights worth the
great coaches do and that Haskins knew
in that 66 season that that issue was a
driving force for them so he played with
it and if you remember the last scene of
the movie where I say you know something
along the lines of you monkeys he calls
them like he makes them enraged at one
point and there was a part of again I go
to what greatcoat and it's to go to Jim
mangled with Ford versus Ferrari it's
what great directors do to do generally
they don't hole you into greatness Josh
Lucas here on the Rich Eisen show before
I let you go what what is outside of
obviously glory road but you're in what
do you consider your favorite sports
movie if you have one that you've seen
because there's so many of them and
glory road is up there many people
mention glory road you say it with your
favorite sports movie grueling happen
reason with recently with the Basketball
Hall of Fame where it got inducted into
the Basketball Hall of Fame it's amazing
congratulations on that he's Bruckheimer
I was very excited about that
I literally can't wait for people to see
four versus four I for that reason no
I'm sure it is it is great the one that
iíve got my basketball one is a Hoosiers
of course I was about to say the one I
probably stole the most from and steal
all the time and nobody would really
ever reference me and Gene Hackman
together but I watched that guy's movies
and steals blatantly from it I think
he's one of the greats out there right I
good to see the way he tied his tie in
that scene just steel yeah
why not on all honesty I feel like I do
that with Marv Albert you know and stuff
that I do honestly know you you know I
mean I'm from New York City so I steal
from him all the time but Hoosiers for
me you know a great sports movie you
need to fire you know you want to talk
soundtracks - I don't we just went
Vangelis with each other right here
chariot Safari oh that's a great one not
many people mention that because I guess
because I guess if you win an Oscar
people think that uh maybe they remove
it I know no but that that's that's
definitely up there hey man Congrats on
Ford vs. Ferrari it really is thank you
for having me no absolutely thank you
for coming here and and I really enjoyed
it I really allow you to come I you know
what let's brockman can you get on that
right that takedown but I've actually
heard truly that he really wants to talk
about his book and he has a right to
talk about his book is he cutting you
can ask him he comes from the world of
sports produce so I know sure if ever be
the head of Disney the most powerful
company on earth I am I'm a former cast
member from my seven years at ESPN so
there's that we have that connection as
well at Josh Lucas on Twitter at J Lucas
the on Instagram you check out this man
along with Matt Damon Christian bailing
and Tracy Letts he's just amazing and
everything that he does in Ford versus
Ferrari in theaters near you Friday
November 15th thanks for coming on I
will say I'm about to write Bob Iger an
email about something else I will
mention that he should go on the Josh
Lucas everybody you are a factor for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app